hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
candy's now we're continuing on to the
second night and I'm actually recording
this after midnight so it's the first
time I've recorded in this dark and
spooky room with this one singular light
and it's after midnight late at night so
let's see what they all want to do with
me here at night Wow why do I have a
message and not a phone draw hello hello
ah see I told you you'd do just fine
anyway I thought I'd mention we we have
this little list of problems that we
have observed with the animatronics over
some time yeah it's it's nothing to be
concerned about those the animatronics
do have a few minor glitches yeah
we're of course trying to get them fixed
but you should know some of them so you
don't get nervous if you hear anything
let me see um the animatronics sometimes
start to walk around on their own
sometimes in the morning we find them in
the strangest places so you may see them
walking around while you hey some of
their sensors are bit wonky in it oh and
in case the animatronics is experiencing
violence towards yes the animatronic
will try to make out the colony and stop
yeah yeah I have no idea how it decides
to do that but it doesn't seem to mind
it with the children it's weird if
they're children playing cops and
robbers you know and one of them gets
shops you know the animatronics don't
really do anything out of the ordinary
okay their honor hey after that day the
animatronics don't really seem to
function properly around adults
especially not around the staff yeah the
animatronics seems to be ignored you
most of the time unless you come near
them and they just turn their heads look
at you like as if you just told a bad
joke I don't know but yeah we kind of
had an accident about a month ago it
seems to have like traumatized their
systems or something like that anyway
we replace the faulty animatronic with
some brand new ones yeah so he stored
way in the back so we get someone to fix
it anyway how are you I keep the other
ones the distance and use the doors if
you have to that would be it for now uh
have a good night thank you for the
message about the violence that's gonna
be enacted upon me okay so now there's a
monkey in play who's kind of got the
foxy Curtin situation going on
like it is this reading situation where
I'm only and I need to worry about how
they're very close to me
because I don't think I want to know
about that hey monkey are you did not
know that I would need to worry about
you oh it's only 2:00 a.m. isn't it oh
goodness gracious well this isn't very
fun also it's very late at night hello
hi monkey
oh you doin are you Jojo is that who you
is are you the ghost of Jojo from the
evil within come to haunt my nightmares
oh that's a lovely song that people are
playing at least the kitties seem to be
staying relatively far away from me but
Jojo the monkey is coming coming on my
way I mean he seems to follow a very set
path so when he moves away from there
I'm gonna be seeing him in my the periph
oh god I'm seeing him in my peripheral
me no likey monkey monkey he's still
there no he's not did he go back man is
he just cycle through that's very foxy
asked I would say that somebody's
copying if there's one thing that
YouTube does not enjoy
that's copious amounts of copying okay
he seems to have gone to beddy-bye by
Jojo needs a little bit of sleep for his
beauty rest he's gonna be just fine but
later on he's gonna crawl on my butt
again
holes quiet I mean the to kitty cats
seem to be relatively content one near
the kitchen one near the entrance to the
party rooms
I'm just Jojo I mean I guess if that's
all that's there on the second night I
don't expect it to be too difficult
because I kind of know the pattern at
this point I mean I'm pretty familiar
with these tense games Dolph I need to
remind thine ears that I'm the king of
some five nights at Freddy's game maybe
maybe I shouldn't brag about that too
loudly they're coming take my crown off
my head who keeps ding dong in
oh no oh oh oh oh where'd he go whoa
wait oh okay I didn't see you there
oh okay all right thanks Jojo you have a
good one
hey kitty kitty are you candy or Cindy I
don't know I don't know if I know which
one and I don't know if I care
good stuff good stuff all around uh oh
god who's that oh oh okay all right they
finally decided to move but I don't know
if that's gonna be oh god oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no I guess I wouldn't be in
trouble unless I saw eyeballs over there
and I know I'm gonna be seeing eyeballs
around me sometime soon up here there
there there oh whoa there's so much more
sinister in the dark and the light
they're almost happy and fun I also read
the developer like rebuilt this game
from the ground up and didn't use any
reason why hey there haha
how you doing kitty cat oh boy oh boy
okay so that's okay I'm gonna be fine
dealing with that oh lordy Lou I'm not
gonna be okay I'm not gonna be okay for
a long time oh geez oh god I'm not gonna
be able to see their eyes cuz they're
gonna be towards towards turns George me
okay we got plenty of artery
where did they go there's one son of a
[ __ ] where is the lady son of a [ __ ]
daughter of a [ __ ] well she's a kitty
cat so I guess it doesn't count okay
we're cool everything's chill
everything's perf everything's chill
again the Dane donggun why does the
ding-dong and keep ding-dang and Weiser
pengon by the way this is the last video
that I'm gonna be recording while I'm
here in Cincinnati I am headed home by
the time you guys are watching this I
should already be back in LA and chica
will begin by loving arms do this
bullcrap anymore well until I said to
pick up the game over there Oh
oh god oh god okay alright okay I see a
move lost track some Oh bollocks
balls oh there you are God
oh hi Jojo how's it going there friend
it's almost time come on ding a head
ding a head damn it dig a head
Oh ding a head already I'm tired of
being scared in the dark also I
shouldn't be yelling I'm waking up my
brother in my mom on such a douchey
child and the literally the worst oh man
I gotta remember the ability to be quiet
which I haven't had for many a year many
a year there's got to be like a separate
animatronic that that goes for the the
center window and something else that I
don't have to worry about just yet oh
man just so creepy sitting in this room
all by my lonesome with no one to keep
me company and this 5 o'clock that's
last for freaking ever God JoJo's on
this way come on come on hey oh I didn't
get I was just yelling god I can't stop
it
Hey Oh Lord
now it's gonna happen
get alone another feed yep it sure is I
don't think I want to go through the
feet I don't even know where the hell
this is going towards no video oh god no
oh no oh
oh no no oh no
I need you shut up they look horrible
what was that hi Jojo
what are you doing here okay so that was
9 to 5 nights of candies I need to pack
up and assemble all my crafts stop doing
that Jojo please dear Lord don't do that
so I need to pack up all my stuff and be
on my way to LA and from then on you'll
be able to see all your favorite series
returning I will be finishing the stuff
that I intended to finish before I left
a long three week vacation but it's been
pretty fun so thanks for being with me
and thank you for being patient when a
16 is gonna be a great year and it
starts today so thank you everybody
again for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye I'm a
winner
okay well I put up a thing